oui non 00h22 dans la nuit du 23 janvier
l' incendie est commencé c'est la
confusion les secours tardent
les pompiers volontaires de l'isle-verte
attendent d'être sur les lieux pour
demander du renfort
la vieille partie de la résidence du
havre n'a pas de gicleurs la nuit et
glacial et le vent et sans merci
en quelques minutes tout s'embrase
devant les pompiers souvent impuissants
30 2 1 m eur
la plupart prisonniers sur leur balcon
jean-luc frazar revois encore en boucle
cette scène où il a tenté de sauver sa
mère l'année l'année a pas été facile je
pensais le faire ce que j'ai fait
j'aurais dû faire dans les jours qui
suivent les fouilles sont difficiles
tout est dévasté et les ruines sont
couvertes de glace
à ce jour trois des 32 victimes n'ont
d'ailleurs pas encore été formellement
identifié
l'isle-verte 1400 personnes réalisent
vite que la vie ne sera plus jamais la
même
c'est traumatisant je parle peu mais ça
veut pas dormir
l' enquête publique du coroner cyrille
delage qui commence en novembre démontre
clairement que le feu a pris naissance
dans la cuisine le corner un reproche
aux préposés de nuit bruno bélanger de
n'avoir rien fait pour sauver des
résidents aya leur poussée weepu chic
égal on lui reproche aussi d'avoir livré
des témoignages contradictoires
serena lui laisse une impression puis au
coeur du problème
l'intervention des pompiers et leur
manque de formation de coordination
québec a donc agi pour les pompiers à
temps partiel yvan charron et ses
collègues sont retournés sur les bancs
d'école des formations bourse larges
morceaux plus de gicleurs sont aussi en
voie d'être imposées dans les résidences
pour personnes âgées
quant au rapport du coroner on connaîtra
bientôt ses conclusions mais on se doute
déjà que la cause exacte de l'incendié
ne sera jamais connue à l'isle-verte
d'auge mois ont passé et un mémorial a
été installé
j'ai le frigo a célébré les funérailles
de chacune des victimes une à une
je pense qu'on prend plus conscience
tout le monde de la beauté de la vie
la grandeur de fragilité le vix un curé
et son village unis pour continuer sans
jamais oublier